next guest became an international
superstar as a member of destiny's child
alma lava i got was i was in the video
in my
in my brain movie since then she's gone
to a successful solo career as a singer
and she's out now with a new book called
checking in say hello to michelle
williams
hello i'm so honored to have you on this
show i love you already and we don't
even know each other so i sound like a
stalker
it i am so excited to be
on your show congratulations thank you i
just
when i see my fellow peers in music
transition on to other passions so
thank you for having me yeah well thank
you so much well speaking of transition
you have a book out now that's amazing
and i love how honest it is it's called
checking in
and i feel like a lot of people are
going to relate to this and i think it
might help a lot of people get through a
lot of their depression and anxiety
how did you feel comfortable enough to
open up about that
well um i'll back back to about 2013
i was doing an interview and it was so
conversational
and i kind of just blurted it out that i
had been
dealing with depression for a long time
since about seventh grade
and fast forward to you know 2018
i had another incident you know it was a
dark moment for me and i
ended up having to check in and i
voluntarily checked in to a mental
health facility
and um i think i wanted to
try to be a voice for people who
like for me i went from the 7th grade to
my 30s without a name for what i had
been feeling which was depression
and to bring hope is
really my ultimate goal well in the book
you talk about
um checking in with others so what does
that mean with you
um for me as far as checking in with
others you know i have a very small
circle
and so during this pandemic we've
learned to be
more intentional and not take anything
for granted
you know when we were told to lock down
i'm a homebody anyway so it worked out
for me
i love being home me too adorable
you know but my heart goes out to people
who thrive
with you know having to have human
connection but
honey it was a lot of you know
video face timing phone calls
texting just checking on each other more
so than often and i think my friendships
were actually strengthened
that's great i do think so too i think
especially because a lot of us were
you know broken down jobs in a way it
was kind of like we all kind of had it
was a lot of self-reflection i think
a lot more than people thought was going
to happen in 2020 um
but we talked with kelly rowland a few
months ago actually and she said
that you were in the room on zoom for
the birth of her son
which is crazy i mean it's super special
but also like
what like you saw all that
[Laughter]
yeah that is friendship
listen if i ever
doubted my place in kelly rowland's life
give me the invitation to watch a her
giving birth
put all doubt out the window oh my gosh
that
would scar me like i'm glad i never saw
that before i got pregnant i would have
never tried it
you know what michelle i'm so different
i'm so different
[Laughter]
so what do you say when people ask you
about like a destiny shotgun i know
people have to ask about it all the time
but i feel like y'all hang all the time
you're always together probably
but you just probably aren't doing music
stuff all the time that is correct
we're not doing music at the moment but
we're together more so than not if it's
if it's together or just
even just yesterday doing a facetime
chat
um i love i love the ladies i'm here for
singing together again
i think we do some of the dopest music
and
um arrangements together um so we'll see
i'm always open to um doing music again
with beyonce and kelly
always it's just such a yeah wow the
chemistry is amazing i love you guys i
love you as well
um everybody michelle's book is called
checking in
how getting real about depression saved
my life and can save yours
you gotta check it out we all need this
right now want more fun stuff
i thought so check out these videos
floating around my head
this one is really cool i'm just saying
no pressure